bienvenido de nuevo a Comprensión de la información y la computación cuántica, me llamo John Watus y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM
Quantum, esta es la lección número 15 de la serie y es la tercera lección de la cuarta unidad, que trata sobre el error cuántico
corrección; hasta ahora hemos visto algunos ejemplos de códigos correctores de errores cuánticos, incluido el código Shore de nueve qubits
el código Steen de 7 qubits y el código de 5 qubits, y también hemos hablado del formalismo estabilizador, que proporcio
nos proporciona una base matemática desde la cual podemos describir y analizar estos y muchos otros códigos correctores de errores cuánticos
los códigos que acabo de mencionar son sin duda interesantes y representan un punto de partida natural para
la exploración de la corrección de errores cuánticos; el problema es que solo pueden tolerar una tasa de error muy baja
corregir un error en un qubit de cinco, siete o nueve no está mal, pero con toda probabilidad, al menos según sospechamos
vamos a necesitar poder tolerar muchos más errores que eso para hacer realidad la computación cuántica a gran escala
en esta lección daremos un primer vistazo a algunas construcciones de códigos correctores de errores cuánticos más sofisticadas, incluyendo códigos que pueden
tolerar una tasa de error mucho mayor que los que hemos visto hasta ahora y se consideran candidatos prometedores para la corrección práctica de errores cuánticos en
dispositivos físicos reales; aquí hay una breve descripción general de la lección: comenzaremos con una clase de
códigos correctores de errores cuánticos conocidos como códigos CSS, nombrados así por los investigadores que los descubrieron: Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor y Andrew Steen; la construcción del código CSS permite tomar ciertos pares de códigos clásicos
correctores de errores y combinarlos en un código corrector de errores cuántico; como parte de esa discusión
echaremos un vistazo bastante rápido a los códigos lineales clásicos y también hablaremos sobre algunas de las propiedades básicas de los códigos CSS
la segunda parte de la lección trata sobre un código conocido como el código Tórico, que es un ejemplo fundamental y realmente
hermoso de un código corrector de errores cuántico que puede tolerar una tasa de error relativamente alta; de hecho el
código Tórico no es un solo ejemplo de un código corrector de errores cuántico, sino que es una familia infinita de códigos, uno para
cada entero positivo a partir de dos, y en la última parte de la lección discutiremos brevemente un par de otras
familias de códigos cuánticos, incluyendo los códigos de superficie, que están estrechamente conectados al código tórico, así como
los códigos de color; la gente ha estado estudiando los códigos correctores de errores clásicos desde la década de 1940
y es un tema fascinante y rico; los códigos lineales son quizás el tipo más simple de error clásico
corrección, y voy a explicar exactamente qué significa la palabra lineal en este contexto en un momento, pero una forma simple
de expresar lo que son es que son códigos estabilizadores que resultan ser clásicos, y veremos en breve que
los códigos CSS son básicamente pares de códigos lineales clásicos que se combinan para crear un error cuántico
código corrector; así que para esa discusión vamos a necesitar entender algunas cosas básicas sobre
los códigos lineales clásicos; primero, vamos a tomar Sigma como el alfabeto binario para toda esta
discusión, y ahora cuando nos referimos a un código lineal clásico, queremos decir un conjunto C de cadenas binarias de longitud n para algún
entero positivo n que satisface una sola propiedad básica, que es que si u y v son cadenas binarias en C, entonces la cadena
u XOR v también está en C; aquí, por cierto, u XOR v significa el OR exclusivo bit a bit de u y v, igual
que vimos varias veces en las lecciones cinco y seis en la parte de algoritmos cuánticos de la serie; y esto es lo que significa que un
código clásico sea lineal; en esencia, estamos pensando en las cadenas binarias de longitud n como vectores de dimensión n
donde las entradas son todas cero o uno, pero en lugar de la adición vectorial ordinaria sobre los números reales o complejos
estamos usando la adición módulo 2, que es simplemente el XOR; así que si tenemos
dos palabras código u y v, es decir, u y v son cadenas binarias en C, entonces u más v módulo 2, o en otras palabras u XOR
v, también debe ser una palabra código en C; y por cierto, esta implicación tiene que ser cierta incluso si u es igual a v; nada descarta
esa posibilidad, y eso implica que todo código lineal clásico debe contener la cadena de todos ceros, porque el
XOR bit a bit de cualquier cadena consigo misma es la cadena de todos ceros; por ejemplo, el
código de repetición de tres bits es un código lineal clásico; en particular hay dos posibles opciones para u y dos posibles
opciones para v, y es un asunto bastante trivial revisar los posibles pares para ver que siempre obtenemos una palabra código cuando tomamos el
XOR bit a bit; aquí hay otro ejemplo que se llama el código de Hamming 743; este es uno de los primeros errores clásicos
códigos correctores que se descubrieron, y consiste en 16 cadenas binarias de longitud siete; hay una lógica muy simple
detrás de la selección de estas cadenas, pero no lo voy a explicar en este video, y también debo mencionar que a veces verás estas cadenas invertidas, pero
por ahora el punto principal es que si tomamos dos de estas cadenas y hacemos XOR entre ellas, obtendremos otra cadena en el
código, por lo que es un código lineal; y la notación 743 entre corchetes simples significa algo análogo a la doble
corchete que mencioné en la lección anterior para los códigos estabilizadores, pero aquí es para los códigos lineales clásicos
en particular, las palabras código tienen siete bits; hay 16 palabras código, por lo que podemos codificar cuatro bits usando el código, y
resulta ser un código de distancia tres, lo que significa que hay que voltear al menos tres bits de cualquier palabra código para obtener
una palabra código diferente, y eso implica que puede corregir hasta un error de volteo de bit; estos son ejemplos simples de
códigos, pero incluso el ejemplo del código de Hamming 743 parece bastante misterioso cuando simplemente listamos todas las palabras código, así que necesitamos mejores formas de
describir los códigos lineales clásicos, y hay dos formas naturales de hacer esto; una forma es describir los códigos lineales clásicos
dando un conjunto mínimo de palabras código que generan el código, lo que significa que tomando todos los posibles
subconjuntos de estas palabras código y haciendo XOR entre ellos obtenemos el código completo, y eso se expresa en términos matemáticos
aquí en la pantalla; otra forma de pensar en esto es que estamos viendo este código como un subespacio de un espacio vectorial, y este conjunto
de generadores es una base para ese subespacio, teniendo en cuenta que este es un espacio vectorial donde la aritmética se hace módulo 2; si tenemos m generadores
terminaremos con un código que tiene dos elevado a la m elementos; cada generador duplica el número de elementos en el código, y
eso es consistente con el hecho de que los códigos lineales clásicos sobre el alfabeto binario siempre incluyen un número de cadenas que es una potencia de
dos; la segunda forma natural de describir un código lineal clásico es mediante verificaciones de paridad; específicamente, esta es una
lista mínima de cadenas binarias que tienen la misma longitud que las cadenas del código, de modo que las cadenas del código son precisamente aquellas cuyo
producto punto binario con cada una de estas cadenas de verificación de paridad es cero, donde el producto punto binario es simplemente el
producto interno módulo 2; y de nuevo, eso es algo que encontramos en la lección cinco en el contexto de los algoritmos de consulta
y la razón por la que se llaman cadenas de verificación de paridad es que una cadena u dada tiene producto binario igual a
cero con v si y solo si los bits de U correspondientes a los unos en V tienen paridad par
cuando describimos un código lineal clásico de esta manera mediante una lista mínima de cadenas de verificación de paridad, cada verificación de paridad
divide el número de cadenas en el código por dos, así que para un único código descrito de estas dos formas distintas siempre tendremos m + R igual a
n. Una cosa importante a notar aquí es que el producto punto binario no es un producto interno en el sentido formal, y en
particular, cuando dos cadenas tienen producto punto binario igual a cero no significa que sean ortogonales en el sentido habitual en que pensamos la
ortogonalidad. Por ejemplo, el producto punto binario de la cadena uno uno consigo misma es cero, así que es posible que
una de estas cadenas de verificación de paridad esté en el propio código, así que eso es algo que hay que tener en
mente. Por ejemplo, como ya sabemos, el código de repetición de 3 bits es un código lineal, así que puede describirse de ambas de estas
formas. En particular, solo hay una opción para un generador que funcione y es 111, y podemos describir alternativamente
el código con estas dos cadenas de verificación de paridad, que deberían resultar familiares de nuestras discusiones previas sobre este
código. Y para el código Hamming de 7-4-3 podemos usar estos generadores y estas verificaciones de paridad
y aquí, por cierto, todas nuestras cadenas de verificación de paridad resultan estar a su vez en el código
código. Un comentario final sobre los códigos lineales clásicos, solo para conectarlos con el formalismo estabilizador: estas verificaciones de paridad
son equivalentes a generadores estabilizadores donde solo tenemos matrices de Pauli Z e identidad. Por ejemplo, la verificación de paridad
de las cadenas 11 0 y 011 para el código de repetición de 3 bits corresponde precisamente a los generadores estabilizadores ZZ identidad
e identidad ZZ, y eso es coherente con nuestra discusión sobre observables de este tipo de la lección
anterior. A continuación hablaremos de los códigos CSS, que son códigos estabilizadores que se pueden obtener combinando ciertos
pares de códigos lineales clásicos con el mismo número de bits en sus codificaciones. Esto no funciona con cualquier par de
códigos lineales clásicos: los dos códigos tienen que tener cierta relación, como veremos pronto, pero aun así esta
construcción abre muchas posibilidades para códigos correctores de errores cuánticos, basados en parte en cosas que hemos aprendido de más de 75 años de
teoría de códigos clásica. Ya mencioné que en el formalismo estabilizador, los generadores estabilizadores
que contienen solo matrices de Pauli Z e identidad son equivalentes a verificaciones de paridad. Por ejemplo, en el código de repetición de tres bits
podemos usar las cadenas de verificación de paridad 1 1 0 y 011, que imponen que los dos bits más a la izquierda sean
iguales y que los dos bits más a la derecha sean iguales para cada cadena del código, y estas dos cadenas de verificación de paridad corresponden precisamente a los generadores estabilizadores
ZZ identidad e identidad ZZ. Para el código Hamming de 7-4-3 podemos usar
estas cadenas de verificación de paridad, y corresponden a estos generadores estabilizadores donde simplemente reemplazamos cada uno por una Z y cada cero por la identidad
Puede que reconozcas estos generadores estabilizadores, porque son tres de los seis generadores estabilizadores del código Steane de 7 qubit. Eso
desde luego no es una coincidencia, y veremos exactamente qué está pasando aquí pronto. Vamos a dar el nombre Z
generadores estabilizadores a generadores estabilizadores como este, es decir, que solo tienen factores tensoriales de Pauli Z e identidad
así que X e Y nunca aparecen en un generador estabilizador Z. También podemos considerar
generadores estabilizadores donde solo aparecen matrices de Pauli X e identidad, y podemos pensar en generadores estabilizadores como este como completamente análogos
a los generadores estabilizadores Z, excepto que básicamente describen verificaciones de paridad en la base más/menos en lugar de la
base estándar. Por ejemplo, volviendo al código Hamming de 7-4-3, podemos pensar en los
tres generadores estabilizadores restantes del código Steane de 7 qubit, que siguen exactamente el mismo patrón que los generadores estabilizadores Z para este
código, pero esta vez sustituimos X por uno en lugar de Z, y lo que obtenemos de solo estos tres generadores estabilizadores
es un código que incluye los 16 estados que se muestran aquí, los cuales obtenemos aplicando gates Hadamard a los estados de la base estándar
que corresponden a las cadenas del código Hamming de 7-4-3, y por supuesto el espacio del código también incluye
combinaciones lineales de estos estados. Naturalmente, los generadores estabilizadores de esta forma se llaman generadores estabilizadores X
así que esta vez no se permiten Y ni Z, y ahora podemos definir los códigos CSS en
términos simples: los códigos CSS son códigos estabilizadores que pueden expresarse usando solo
generadores estabilizadores Z y generadores estabilizadores X, así que no se permiten Y ni X y Z en el mismo generador estabilizador
y para asegurarnos de que esto queda claro, hay que tener en mente que existe libertad en cómo elegimos los generadores estabilizadores para los códigos estabilizadores
y lo que dice esta definición es que un código CSS es aquel para el que es posible elegir solo generadores estabilizadores Z y X
pero en general podrías elegir distintos generadores estabilizadores que no sean generadores estabilizadores Z o X si quisieras
Aquí tenemos el ejemplo no trivial más simple de un código CSS que podemos tener, donde hay tanto un generador estabilizador Z
como un generador estabilizador X, y verificarlo no requiere más que un vistazo, dado que ya sabemos por
la lección anterior que este es un código estabilizador válido. El espacio del código es unidimensional, es el espacio generado por un
ebit más y podemos observar que nuestros dos generadores estabilizadores actúan trivialmente sobre este vector considerando
las dos expresiones de un ebit que se muestran en pantalla, junto con la interpretación de los generadores estabilizadores como verificaciones de paridad en los bases 01
y más/menos. El código Steane de 7 qubit es otro ejemplo de código CSS, porque para esta
elección de generadores solo tenemos generadores estabilizadores Z y X, y ya sabemos que este es un
código estabilizador válido. El código de 9 qubit de Shor es otro ejemplo: esta vez tenemos seis generadores Z
estabilizadores y solo dos generadores estabilizadores X, y eso está bien, no tiene que haber equilibrio ni
simetría entre los dos tipos. Sin embargo, sí es fundamental que tengamos un código estabilizador válido, y eso significa
que cada uno de los generadores estabilizadores Z debe conmutar con cada uno de los generadores estabilizadores X, así que no puedes
simplemente elegir los dos tipos de generadores de forma independiente, y ya hablaré un poco más sobre esto más adelante en la lección. A continuación hablaremos de la detección
y corrección de errores para los códigos CSS, y lo que encontraremos es que la propiedad que observamos para el código de 9 qubit de Shor
de que podemos detectar y corregir errores X y errores Z de forma independiente se cumple en general para los códigos CSS
Para explicar esto con más detalle, consideremos un código CSS como el código Steane de 7 qubit, aunque podría ser un código CSS diferente si
lo prefieres. La idea básica es que los generadores estabilizadores Z detectan errores X
pero son completamente insensibles a los errores Z, porque los generadores estabilizadores Z siempre conmutan con los errores Z
Además, los generadores estabilizadores Z también conmutan con los gates Z que podríamos elegir aplicar como
correcciones para errores Z. De manera similar, los generadores estabilizadores X detectan errores Z pero son completamente
insensibles a los errores X y las correcciones, así que podemos en esencia pensar en los generadores estabilizadores Z como representando un
código lineal clásico que protege contra bit flips, o en otras palabras errores X, mientras que los generadores estabilizadores X
representar un código lineal clásico en la base más-menos que protege de forma completamente independiente contra los flip
entre los estados más y menos, o en otras palabras, errores de phase flip o errores Z, así que ahora es bastante evidente lo que está pasando
con el código de Steane: es simplemente un código de Hamming 7-4-3 para errores de bit flip y un código de Hamming 7-4-3 para errores de phase flip
los generadores de estabilizadores Z y los generadores de estabilizadores X deben conmutar, eso es un requisito indispensable
no sería un código estabilizador válido si no lo hicieran, y podrías decir que es una gran suerte que el código de Hamming 7-4-3
funcione así, pero hay muchas otras opciones que se pueden elegir para pares de códigos lineales clásicos que nos darán un código estabilizador válido
cuando se combinan de esta manera. Ahora, volviendo a los códigos CSS en general, supongamos que los generadores de estabilizadores Z
permiten la corrección de hasta, digamos, JX errores, y los generadores de estabilizadores X permiten la corrección de
hasta k errores Z; así que en el caso del código de Steane, J y K son ambos uno, porque
el código de Hamming 7-4-3 puede corregir un bit flip, pero en general estos números J y K podrían ser distintos
luego se deduce, por la discretización de errores, que el código CSS puede corregir cualquier error en un número de qubits de hasta
el mínimo de J y K; esto se debe a que cuando medimos el síndrome, un error arbitrario en algunos
qubits colapsa probabilísticamente en alguna combinación de errores X, errores Z o ambos, y luego
los errores X y los errores Z pueden detectarse y corregirse de forma independiente, así que mientras tengamos dos
códigos lineales clásicos que se lleven bien, en el sentido de que nos den generadores de estabilizadores X y Z que conmuten,
el código CSS que obtenemos al combinarlos básicamente hereda las propiedades de corrección de errores de los dos códigos, en el sentido que acabo de
describir. Fíjate que hay un precio que pagar, y es que no podemos codificar tantos qubits como podríamos codificar bits
con los dos códigos clásicos, porque el número total de generadores de estabilizadores del código CSS es la suma de los
controles de paridad de los dos códigos clásicos, y cada generador de estabilizadores reduce a la mitad la dimensión del espacio de código
por ejemplo, el código de Hamming 7-4-3 permite codificar cuatro bits clásicos porque tenemos solo
tres controles de paridad para este código, mientras que el código de Steane de 7 qubits solo codifica un qubit porque tiene seis
generadores de estabilizadores. Lo último que voy a explicar sobre los códigos CSS en general en esta lección tiene que ver con los espacios de código de los códigos CSS
y cómo son, y esto también nos dará la oportunidad de examinar con un poco más de detalle la relación que debe existir entre
dos códigos lineales clásicos para que sean compatibles, de modo que podamos combinarlos para formar un código CSS
considera un código CSS arbitrario sobre N qubits, y sean Z1 hasta Zs las cadenas de N bits
que corresponden a los generadores de estabilizadores Z; esto significa que el código
lineal clásico descrito por los generadores de estabilizadores Z, que llamaremos CZ para recordar que este
es el código correspondiente a los generadores de estabilizadores Z, toma la forma que se muestra aquí en pantalla; en palabras, el código contiene cada
cadena U cuyo producto punto binario con cada una de las cadenas de paridad es cero; bueno, si quisiéramos también podríamos
considerar un código diferente derivado de estas mismas cadenas, al que llamaremos DZ, y la idea aquí es que pensamos en
estas cadenas Z1 hasta Zs no como cadenas de paridad, sino como generadores
en este punto no está claro por qué querríamos pensar en este código, pero podemos hacerlo y resultará ser relevante para esta
discusión; este código se llama el código dual de CZ y se denota comúnmente como CZ al perp, es decir, CZ con el símbolo perpendicular
como superíndice, pero nosotros lo llamaremos DZ y será fácil de recordar porque D es la abreviatura de
dual; también podemos hacer algo similar con los generadores de estabilizadores X, así que esta vez CX es el código lineal clásico
cuyas cadenas de paridad corresponden a los generadores de estabilizadores X, y DX es el código dual de este código; como nota al margen,
ahora podemos describir las condiciones que deben cumplirse para que CZ y CX sean compatibles, en el sentido de que podamos
combinarlos como un código CSS, en términos de estos propios códigos; concretamente, se requiere que
DZ esté contenido en CX, o de manera equivalente, que DX esté contenido en CZ, y ahora es
posible describir el espacio de código del código CSS derivado de estos dos códigos; una forma de describirlo es que
es el espacio generado por todos los vectores que toman la forma que se muestra en pantalla; en palabras, parecen superposiciones uniformes
sobre las cadenas del código dual DX del código correspondiente a los generadores de estabilizadores X, desplazadas
mediante XOR con cadenas del código CZ correspondiente a los generadores de estabilizadores Z; y veremos cómo se ve esto
en el caso específico del código de Steane en un momento; esto tiene sentido porque los estados en el espacio de código deben ser
vectores propios de valor +1 de todos los generadores de estabilizadores, y en particular multiplicar por cualquiera de los
generadores de estabilizadores X equivale a aplicar XOR con la cadena X correspondiente, por eso estas superposiciones uniformes
sobre DX desplazadas por distintas cadenas aparecen de esta manera; las distintas elecciones para el desplazamiento
representado por la cadena Y en esta expresión pueden darnos el mismo vector, por cierto, así que estos estados no son todos distintos, pero en conjunto abarcan el
espacio de código completo; hay una simetría aquí entre los generadores de estabilizadores X y Z y
los códigos a los que corresponden, así que podemos usar esa simetría para describir los vectores en el espacio de código de manera análoga intercambiando X y Z, pero
también necesitamos intercambiar las bases estándar por las bases más-menos, por eso aparecen las operaciones Hadamard en esta
expresión; ahora, para el ejemplo que prometí, que es el código de Steane, terminamos con estas dos posibles
codificaciones de los estados de la base estándar cero y uno; en particular, podemos codificar el estado cero como una superposición uniforme
sobre las ocho cadenas del código dual del código de Hamming 7-4-3, que resulta ser la mitad de las cadenas del código de Hamming 7-4-3, y
podemos codificar el estado uno de manera similar, excepto que todas las cadenas están sometidas a XOR con la cadena de todos unos en este caso
porque esa cadena está en el código de Hamming 7-4-3 pero no en su dual; un comentario final aquí es que a menudo
no nos importa demasiado cómo se ven los vectores en nuestros espacios de código, porque generalmente no necesitamos saberlo para usar los
códigos, así que si esta explicación no quedó clara, realmente no es algo de lo que preocuparse demasiado, pero ciertamente es
natural preguntarse cómo se ven los vectores en los espacios de código de los códigos CSS, y esta descripción proporciona una respuesta a esa
pregunta; a continuación hablaremos de un código CSS específico conocido como el código tórico, que es un ejemplo de algo conocido como un
código de corrección de errores cuántico topológico; este código fue descubierto por Alexei Kitaev en
1997; de hecho, el código tórico no es un único código sino una familia de códigos, uno para cada entero positivo de
al menos dos; estos códigos poseen algunas propiedades clave; la primera propiedad clave es
que todos los generadores de estabilizadores tienen peso bajo como operaciones de Pauli; en particular, todos van a tener
peso cuatro, y esto es bueno porque significa que cada una de las mediciones de los generadores de estabilizadores no necesita
a veces involucran demasiados qubits; a veces la gente habla de códigos LDPC cuánticos o códigos cuánticos de paridad de baja densidad
y esto es lo que significa ese término, donde en este caso "baja" significa cuatro, por lo que el código Tor es un ejemplo de un
código LDPC cuántico. El código Tor también tiene lo que se llama localidad geométrica, lo que significa que no
solo los generadores estabilizadores tienen peso bajo, sino que también es posible organizar los qubits espacialmente de modo que
cada una de las mediciones de los generadores estabilizadores solo involucre qubits que estén cerca entre sí, lo que hace que estas mediciones sean más fáciles de implementar en
principio. Y finalmente, estos códigos tienen una distancia grande, por lo que pueden tolerar una tasa relativamente alta de
errores. Así es como funcionan estos códigos: primero, sea L un entero positivo
que sea al menos dos, y considera una retícula L por L con las llamadas condiciones de contorno periódicas.
Por ejemplo, aquí hay una retícula L por L para L igual a 8, y fíjate que las líneas
de la derecha y de la parte inferior son líneas punteadas. La idea aquí es que queremos pensar en la línea punteada de la derecha como si fuera la misma línea que
la de la izquierda, y de manera similar, la línea punteada de abajo es la misma línea que la de
arriba. Entonces, si quisiéramos implementar este tipo de configuración físicamente, necesitaríamos tres
dimensiones. En particular, podríamos formar un cilindro uniendo primero los lados izquierdo y derecho, y luego doblar el
cilindro de modo que los círculos en los extremos, que antes eran los bordes superior e inferior de la retícula, se unan. O bien,
podrías unir primero la parte superior e inferior y luego los lados. Funciona de las dos maneras y no importa cuál elijas. Para los fines de esta
discusión, lo que obtenemos es un toro, o en otras palabras, una dona, aunque pensarlo como el tubo interior de un neumático es
quizás una imagen más adecuada, ya que esto no es un sólido: la retícula se ha convertido en simplemente la superficie de un
toro. Y de aquí viene el nombre "código Tor". La forma en que puedes moverte por
un toro como este, asumiendo que puedes moverte entre puntos adyacentes de la retícula, probablemente les resultará familiar a quienes han jugado videojuegos clásicos,
donde si te mueves más allá del borde superior de la pantalla, apareces por abajo, y lo mismo ocurre con los bordes izquierdo y derecho de la
pantalla. Y en su mayor parte, así es como voy a describir esta retícula, en lugar de hablar específicamente sobre un
toro en un espacio tridimensional. A continuación, imaginamos que los qubits están
colocados en los bordes de la retícula, tal como se ilustra aquí en pantalla, donde los qubits están indicados por círculos azules sólidos.
Fíjate, por cierto, que los qubits ubicados en las líneas punteadas no son sólidos, y eso es porque ya representamos esos qubits
ya sea con los de la parte superior o los del lado izquierdo, teniendo en cuenta que las líneas de arriba y de la izquierda son exactamente las mismas que las
indicadas por las líneas punteadas de abajo y la derecha. Entonces, si contamos todos estos qubits, obtenemos 2 × L² qubits, y una
forma de verlo es observar que obtenemos L² qubits en los bordes horizontales y L² qubits en los bordes verticales.
Ese es el diseño de nuestros qubits. Y para describir el código Tor en sí, solo necesitamos describir los generadores estabilizadores.
Y hay dos tipos de ellos. Primero, tenemos los generadores estabilizadores Z,
que corresponden a las celdas o plaquetas en la figura. Y segundo, tenemos los generadores estabilizadores X,
que corresponden a los vértices en la figura. Por ejemplo, aquí hay un
generador estabilizador, lo que significa que estamos haciendo el producto tensorial de una operación Pauli Z para cada uno de los qubits que tocan esta celda, junto con matrices identidad
en todos los demás qubits. Eso nos da una operación Pauli de peso cuatro. Y aquí hay un ejemplo de un generador estabilizador X,
donde tenemos matrices Pauli X actuando sobre los cuatro qubits incidentes a este vértice, junto con
matrices identidad en todos los demás qubits. Una vez más, es una operación Pauli de peso cuatro. Es importante que para ambos
tipos de generadores estabilizadores incluyamos los que se envuelven en los contornos periódicos. Aquí hay un ejemplo de un generador estabilizador X
que hace esto. Ahora bien, para obtener un código estabilizador válido, necesitamos que los generadores estabilizadores
conmuten. Los generadores estabilizadores Z conmutan entre sí porque Z conmuta consigo mismo y la identidad
conmuta con todo. Y lo mismo ocurre con los generadores estabilizadores X. También es claro que un generador estabilizador Z y uno X
conmutan cuando actúan de manera no trivial sobre conjuntos disjuntos de qubits, como en el caso de los dos generadores que se muestran
aquí. La posibilidad restante es que un generador estabilizador Z y un generador estabilizador X se solapen, y
cuando eso ocurre, siempre son dos qubits en los que se solapan, por lo que los generadores estabilizadores conmutan porque ZZ
y XX conmutan. Ahora bien, este no es un conjunto mínimo de generadores estabilizadores. En particular, si multiplicamos
todos los generadores estabilizadores Z juntos, obtenemos la identidad, porque cada qubit se multiplica por Z dos veces,
una por cada una de las celdas que toca ese qubit. Eso significa que multiplicar todos los generadores estabilizadores Z juntos
excepto uno nos da ese último, por lo que no son independientes. Pero si eliminamos cualquiera de ellos, obtendremos
un conjunto independiente. Y lo mismo es válido para los generadores estabilizadores X, por lo que podemos eliminar uno de cada tipo,
y no importa cuáles eliminemos. Eso nos deja con L² menos uno generadores estabilizadores de cada tipo. Para
ser claros al respecto, y esto es algo que mencioné en la lección anterior, en realidad sí nos importan todos estos generadores estabilizadores y, en un sentido estrictamente
operacional, no vamos a elegir uno de cada tipo para ignorarlo. Pero para analizar el código, podemos
imaginar que se ha eliminado un generador estabilizador de cada tipo, de modo que obtenemos un conjunto generador mínimo, teniendo en
cuenta que siempre podríamos inferir los resultados de esos generadores eliminados, considerándolos como observables, a partir de los resultados de todos los demás generadores estabilizadores
observables del mismo tipo. Así que el número de qubits que codifica este código es igual al número total de
qubits, que es 2 × L², menos el número total de generadores estabilizadores en un conjunto generador mínimo, que es 2 × L² −
1, y eso significa que podemos codificar 2 qubits. No demostré, por cierto, que el espacio de código sea no trivial, pero sí lo es,
y te dejo que te convenzas de que no hay forma de multiplicar generadores estabilizadores de manera que obtengamos
−1 por la identidad. Ese es el código Tor en sí, y en este punto puede que no esté
del todo claro por qué este código debería ser bueno para la corrección de errores cuánticos. Nos queda analizarlo, y lo que encontraremos es que es, en
efecto, un código corrector de errores cuánticos bastante asombroso. Para entender cómo funciona el código Tor como código corrector de errores cuánticos,
empezaremos por considerar los distintos errores y los síndromes que generan. Lo primero que hay que destacar es que
el código Tor es un código CSS porque todos nuestros generadores estabilizadores son o bien generadores estabilizadores Z o X.
Y lo que eso significa es que los errores X y los errores Z pueden detectarse y posiblemente corregirse
por separado. Y de hecho, hay una simetría simple entre los generadores estabilizadores Z y X que nos permite analizar los errores X
y los errores Z de esencialmente la misma manera. Así que me voy a centrar en los errores X, que son posiblemente detectados por los generadores estabilizadores Z,
y puedes trasladar todo lo relativo a los errores Z, que son posiblemente detectados por los generadores estabilizadores X, usando exactamente la
las mismas ideas. Aquí hay una figura que ilustra nuestros dos qubits cuadrados en los bordes de una L
por una red con condiciones de frontera periódicas, y podemos imaginar que esto está dispuesto en la superficie de un
toro. Por ahora, todos los qubits son azules, lo que indica que son qubits que no han sido afectados por
errores. Así que deberías imaginar que en este punto el estado de estos qubits está en el espacio de código para este
código. Como mencioné, nuestro enfoque estará en los errores X, y en un momento usaremos círculos magenta para indicar qubits que
han sido afectados por errores X. Los errores X se detectan mediante generadores de estabilizadores Z, que corresponden
a los bloques de la figura. Entonces, lo que podemos hacer es dejar que los bloques blancos indiquen resultados de medición de más uno, o en otras palabras,
entradas en el síndrome correspondientes a ese generador, mientras que los bloques grises indicarán mediciones de menos uno
Puedes pensar en un resultado de más uno, o en otras palabras un bloque blanco, como una indicación de que el correspondiente
generador de estabilizadores está contento: todo parece estar bien para este generador. Un resultado de menos uno o un bloque gris
indica que el generador de estabilizadores correspondiente está descontento, porque obviamente debe haber ocurrido un error para causar este
resultado. Así que por ahora todos nuestros generadores de estabilizadores están contentos porque no han ocurrido errores. Ahora si pensamos
en un generador de estabilizadores Z, lo único que hace es medir la paridad de los 4 qubits que tocan el bloque con
respecto a la base estándar. Así que un resultado de más uno no indica que no hayan ocurrido errores X en estos cuatro
qubits, sino que indica que ha ocurrido un número par de errores X, mientras que un resultado de menos uno indica
que ha ocurrido un número impar de errores X. Ahora introduzcamos un error X y veamos qué
pasa. Los dos generadores de estabilizadores Z correspondientes a los bloques que tocan este qubit ahora están descontentos porque este
error X anti-conmuta con ambos generadores, o equivalentemente en términos de la base estándar, ahora estamos en
un estado donde ambos conjuntos de cuatro qubits correspondientes a los dos bloques tienen paridad impar. Ese es el efecto de un único
error X. Así que si midiéramos este síndrome y supiéramos o asumiéramos que solo había ocurrido un error X, podríamos
inferir fácilmente qué qubit se flippeó y simplemente podríamos flipearlo de vuelta con un gate X. Ahora veamos qué pasa
cuando introducimos errores X adicionales, y en particular veamos qué pasa cuando ocurre un segundo error X en otro
qubit que toca uno de los bloques grises. Digamos el bloque gris de arriba, como
este. Ese bloque ahora está contento porque han ocurrido dos errores X en los qubits que tocan este bloque, y dos es par. Así que
estos dos errores X juntos conmutan con el generador de estabilizadores de este bloque. Otra forma de decir esto es que
este segundo error X ha desplazado todos los estados de la base estándar de estos cuatro qubits desde paridad impar de vuelta a par.
El bloque a la izquierda de este nuevo error X, en cambio, ahora está descontento.
Podemos continuar este proceso de añadir nuevos errores X, y siempre que formemos una cadena de errores X adyacentes —donde adyacente significa que los qubits tocan el
mismo bloque— efectivamente empujaremos este resultado de medición de menos uno, y lo que encontramos es que siempre tenemos
resultados de medición del síndrome de menos uno en los extremos de cadenas de errores adyacentes. Así que siempre podemos detectar cadenas de
errores X adyacentes siempre que tengan extremos. Por cierto, podría haber múltiples cadenas, pero volveremos
a esta posibilidad más adelante. Sin embargo, es posible que tengamos una cadena de errores X adyacentes que
no tenga extremos, es decir, que nuestra cadena de errores podría formar un bucle cerrado. Así que añadamos más errores
para que formen un bucle cerrado como este, por ejemplo. Ahora tenemos un número par de errores X
en cada bloque, así que todos los generadores de estabilizadores están contentos ahora. Y lo que encontramos es que los bucles cerrados
de errores X adyacentes no son detectados por este código, porque obtenemos el síndrome de todos más uno en tal
caso. Eso podría parecer algo decepcionante. De hecho, solo necesitamos cuatro errores X adyacentes para formar un bucle cerrado,
y esperamos algo mejor que un código de distancia 4. Sin embargo, algunos bucles cerrados de
errores X adyacentes están ellos mismos en el estabilizador. Recuerda que tenemos un generador de estabilizadores X para cada vértice en
la red, y si multiplicamos generadores de estabilizadores X adyacentes podemos formar bucles cerrados de operaciones X
como el que tenemos justo aquí para el bucle cerrado que construimos hace unos momentos. Así que algunos bucles cerrados de errores X
como el que se muestra aquí no son errores en absoluto, porque están en el estabilizador. Así que no hacen nada al espacio de código. Sin embargo, hay
algunos bucles cerrados de errores X que no están en el estabilizador y que por tanto representan errores no triviales que pasan
desapercibidos por el código. Y hay una forma bastante sencilla de caracterizar los diferentes tipos de
bucles. Los bucles que cruzan cada línea en la red —es decir, cada línea vertical de arriba a abajo y cada línea horizontal
de izquierda a derecha— un número par de veces son siempre productos de generadores de estabilizadores X. Eso incluye el ejemplo
mostrado en la pantalla, así como bucles que pueden ser mucho más complicados, incluyendo la posibilidad de que crucen las fronteras periódicas, pero
aun así, multiplicando estos bucles cerrados de errores X por generadores de estabilizadores X, pueden efectivamente reducirse a
nada. Y ciertamente es verdad que solo podemos obtener bucles como este multiplicando juntos generadores de estabilizadores X, porque cada estabilizador X
pone un número par de operaciones X en cada línea horizontal y en cada línea vertical.
El otro tipo de bucle cerrado que podemos tener es uno que cruza al menos una línea un número impar de veces, como
el que se muestra aquí, que cruza cada línea horizontal exactamente una vez. Y aquí hay otro ejemplo que cruza
cada línea vertical exactamente una vez. Estos son ejemplos de errores no triviales que pasan desapercibidos por el código, pero la clave
aquí es que la única forma de formar un bucle cerrado como este es dar la vuelta al toro, ya sea alrededor del agujero en el
medio del toro o a través del agujero, o podría ser ambos. Esta es una propiedad topológica
relacionada con el toro: tiene que ver básicamente con los agujeros, y por eso esto se llama corrección de errores cuánticos topológica.
En términos de esta visualización de una red bidimensional con fronteras periódicas, una cadena en esta categoría debe
dar la vuelta a una o ambas fronteras periódicas de una forma que imposibilite contraer ese bucle a un
punto multiplicándolo por generadores de estabilizadores X. Tal cadena puede ser más
complicada que la que se ilustra aquí, pero este es el bucle más corto posible porque tiene que dar la vuelta de algún modo
a una o ambas fronteras periódicas. Y lo que esto implica es que el peso mínimo de un error no trivial
indetectable es L. Cualquier bucle cerrado con menos errores que eso tiene que caer en la primera categoría y por lo tanto
está en el estabilizador. Y las cadenas de errores que no forman bucles cerrados son detectadas por el código. Y eso es todo, por eso funciona este código.
Y lo que obtenemos es un código estabilizador 2 L² 2 L: estamos usando 2 L²
qubits para codificar 2 qubits, y el código tiene distancia L. A continuación diré solo un poco sobre
corrigiendo errores con el código Tórico, aunque no entraré demasiado en los detalles: si medimos el síndrome y
vemos algo distinto del síndrome todo +1, donde me refiero aquí solo a los generadores de estabilizadores Z,
entonces los resultados menos uno nos indican los extremos de una o más cadenas de errores X adyacentes, y podemos intentar corregir
estos errores emparejando los resultados menos uno y formando una cadena de correcciones X entre ellos, y mientras
hacemos esto tiene sentido elegir los caminos más cortos para nuestras correcciones; por ejemplo, si medimos un
síndrome como el que se muestra aquí, podríamos elegir este camino entre las baldosas no satisfechas y aplicar X
gates como correcciones a lo largo de este camino. Por supuesto, la cadena real de errores que causó el síndrome podría haber sido
diferente, como la que se muestra aquí, pero eso está bien siempre que los errores y las correcciones juntos
caigan dentro del estabilizador. También podría ocurrir que nuestras correcciones completen un bucle alrededor del
Toro, lo cual es malo porque al hacerlo hemos causado un error lógico. Así que esta estrategia de corregir
por los caminos más cortos corrige errores de bajo peso, pero puede que no funcione para errores de mayor peso. Claro que no podemos
esperar nada más de ningún código de corrección de errores cuánticos. Quizás más probable, dependiendo del modelo de ruido, es que
observemos un montón de menos unos en el síndrome, y en este caso podemos usar algoritmos clásicos eficientes para ayudarnos
a emparejarlos y encontrar un error de menor peso que represente el síndrome. Como mencioné en la lección anterior,
esto puede que no siempre corrija la explicación más probable del síndrome, pero funciona bastante bien en general
y siempre tiene éxito en corregir errores de peso estrictamente menor que la mitad de la distancia L. Y también debo
mencionar que hay otras estrategias más adecuadas para distintos modelos de error. Han pasado más de 25 años desde que el
código Tórico fue descubierto, y en ese tiempo se ha realizado bastante trabajo sobre códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo
otros códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos topológicos inspirados en el código Tórico, así como códigos basados en ideas diferentes.
Ciertamente no puedo darte una lista exhaustiva de todas las construcciones de códigos conocidas, pero voy a rascar la superficie
un poco y mencionar brevemente un par de ejemplos bien conocidos. Primero, resulta que no es
realmente esencial que el código Tórico tenga fronteras periódicas; es decir, es posible recortar solo una porción del código Tórico y
colocarla plana en una superficie bidimensional en lugar de sobre un Toro, y lo que obtenemos al hacer eso se llama surface
code. Por ejemplo, si cortamos los bordes de una red con el patrón que se muestra aquí, con los llamados bordes rugosos en la parte
superior e inferior, y bordes lisos en los laterales, y correspondientemente incluimos casos de borde para los generadores de estabilizadores,
entonces terminamos con un código que puede codificar solo un qubit en este caso, pero el código hereda de todas formas las
características más importantes del código Tórico. En particular, los errores no triviales indetectables para este código deben
corresponder a cadenas de errores que se extiendan desde el borde izquierdo hasta el borde derecho, o de arriba a abajo,
dependiendo de si son cadenas de errores X o Z respectivamente. También es posible cortar
los bordes en diagonal para obtener lo que a veces se llaman surface codes rotados, y hacer eso puede ser útil para hacer
los códigos más económicos en términos de cuántos qubits se usan. Por ejemplo, si tomamos este surface
code y descartamos algunos de los qubits dejando un cuadrado orientado en diagonal, obtenemos otro surface
code, siempre que especifiquemos los generadores de estabilizadores en el contorno de la manera correcta. Diagramas como este son
útiles para dejar claro cómo se definen los generadores de estabilizadores, donde las baldosas negras, incluidas las redondeadas en los bordes, indican estabilizadores X,
y las blancas indican estabilizadores Z. Las del contorno, por cierto, son simplemente generadores de estabilizadores XX o ZZ de 2 qubits
en este caso, y es común ver estos diagramas rotados
45°. Otra clase interesante de códigos, que también entran en la categoría general de códigos topológicos, son los color
codes. No voy a explicar exactamente cómo funcionan, pero una manera de pensarlos es que son generalizaciones geométricas
del código Steane de 7 qubits. Así que pensemos en el código Steane de 7 qubits y supongamos que numeramos nuestros
qubits usando la convención de ordenamiento KCET, tal como se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Luego podemos asociar estos siete
qubits con los vértices del grafo que se muestra aquí, y lo que encontramos es que los generadores de estabilizadores coinciden
con las baldosas o las caras formadas por los bordes del grafo, y para cada baldosa siempre tenemos un estabilizador Z
y un estabilizador X que actúan de manera no trivial precisamente sobre aquellos qubits que se encuentran en los vértices de esa
baldosa. Esto es bueno porque, al igual que en el código Tórico, tenemos localidad geométrica para este código, así que no necesitamos
mover qubits a grandes distancias para medir los generadores de estabilizadores. El hecho de que los generadores de estabilizadores Z y X siempre actúen de manera no trivial sobre
exactamente los mismos conjuntos de qubits también es bueno por razones relacionadas con la computación cuántica tolerante a fallos, sobre lo que
hablaré más en la próxima lección. Los color codes son códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos que generalizan este
patrón básico, donde hacemos esencialmente lo mismo pero con grafos diferentes. Por ejemplo, aquí hay un grafo con
19 vértices que funciona. Esto nos da un código que codifica 1 qubit en 19, y resulta que tiene
distancia cinco. Se llaman color codes, por cierto, porque una de las condiciones requeridas sobre el grafo es que las caras se puedan colorear con tres colores, lo que significa
que podemos colorear las caras con tres colores y nunca tenemos dos caras del mismo color que compartan un borde. Los
colores en realidad no importan para el código en sí; simplemente tenemos generadores de estabilizadores X y Z para cada cara independientemente de su color, pero los colores
resultan ser importantes para analizar cómo funciona. Así que esas son dos familias de códigos muy conocidas.
Pero hay muchas otras construcciones conocidas, incluyendo unas basadas en ideas similares a estas familias de códigos, así como
otras completamente diferentes. Un ejemplo específico de un código de corrección de errores cuánticos que fue descubierto recientemente
por algunos de mis colegas en IBM es conocido como el gross code, que recibe ese nombre porque un "gross" es una docena de
docenas, es decir, 144. En particular, este código codifica 12 qubits en 144 qubits y tiene
distancia 12. No voy a explicar cómo funciona este código en detalle; es similar al código Tórico, excepto que cada uno de los
generadores de estabilizadores ahora involucra dos qubits adicionales que están solo un poco más lejos. No tiene una representación plana
como un surface code, pero sí tiene lo que se llama una representación en capa, lo que significa que se necesitan dos capas de qubits en lugar de
una sola. Pertenece a una familia de códigos llamados bivariate bicycle codes, y lo que resulta especialmente notable en ellos es
que son mucho más eficientes que el código Tórico o un surface code, en el sentido de que se pueden codificar muchos más qubits mientras que simultáneamente
toleran aproximadamente la misma tasa de errores. Para el gross code, se necesitan 144 qubits adicionales para la medición del síndrome,
de modo que el número total de qubits requeridos es 288, lo que lo convierte en un candidato muy prometedor para la tecnología actual.
Y eso concluye esta lección, que ha tratado sobre construcciones de códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo los códigos CSS, el código Tórico y una
breve mirada a otras construcciones de códigos cuánticos, incluyendo surface codes y color codes. Espero que te unas a mí en la
próxima y última lección de la serie sobre computación cuántica tolerante a fallos, que aborda el desafío de realizar
computaciones en estados cuánticos codificados usando operaciones y componentes de cómputo que ellos mismos son propensos a
errores. Hasta la próxima.